foreign
London
[Music]
five decades ago four young men made
this street famous all around the world
and just a few steps up the street there
on June 25th 1967 they performed a song
live by satellite to an audience of
almost half a billion people
that song was all you need is love
it was a Summer of Love I was working at
a little theater in Vermont when I heard
it I hadn't liked so many young people
everywhere we were swept up by the sense
of hope that love was all you needed to
end War poverty and depression
it's easy
right
seems naive now
let's stop and think for a minute about
how our lives are built around love
families
in our communities
is it really naive to think that love
can change the world
what happens when we don't have love why
these children rocking back and forth
because children were never held as
infants
why are we willing to suffer for love
even die for it what happens on those
battlefields Forge is something that
truly cannot be repeated anywhere else
should passion be left to fate is it
really meant to just be charms that you
meet someone that you're meant to spend
the rest of your life with and can love
reach everyone it's a way of making
someone feel like there's someone out
there who cares
[Music]
this is my journey
to discover the ties that bind us
manifest is the story of us
[Music]
I'm in Southern California
to meet Isadora Ruckel
is a dog grew up in a Romanian orphanage
and didn't experience the love most of
us take for granted
the love of a parent
you were born in Romania that is correct
but you wound up in an orphanage at an
early age I did
my parents took me to a hospital to be
treated for my flu or cold the doctor
gave me an injection and instead of the
needles being sterilized and disinfected
it was used Time After Time on children
after children and I contracted polio
so my parents said what on Earth did you
do to his leg his leg is dead can't move
it anymore
the doctor said he'd have to stay here
for a couple of weeks
the ones my parents left me there they
never came back
at the age of three years old Iris put
in the hospital for the irrecoverable
children and grew up there until I was
11 years old
in the 24 years that Nikolai ciao ruled
Romania
many children shared isador's fate
Josh has to decreed that every family
must have at least five children or pay
an extreme tax penalty
if you couldn't afford to feed five
children often the only option was to
give some of them to one of Romania's
overcrowded State orphanages
so Izzy you spent eight years growing up
in orphanage
what was that like
there are moments where you wonder
am I going to survive this
none of us were taken outside no
sunlight no sunlight
looking around at where we are
playground to trees to Grass we do not
have anything like nothing close to it
no I wanted to show you this video so
you could actually see it for yourself
what my life in the institution was in
Romania
thank you
[Music]
hmm
I mean even the building from the
outside looks intimidating
when you walk into the building it
smells nothing but soaked urine and
fecing
[Music]
my goodness gracious
about how many kids can you think in
that alternate it would be about 400 500
children 500 children and not nearly
enough people to look after them
why these children rocking back and
forth
because children will never help as
infants
and
they were developing ways to nurture
themselves and walking back and forth
was one of the ways you experienced it I
experienced I used to walk back and
forth for a long time and I grew out of
the out of that eventually
who was that kid
that was me that was me in 1990 I had
more opportunity than others I had a
worker named omisha and I actually still
have her picture
and um
I will never forget this woman she was
one of the most amazing
workers that worked there
onisha took me home for one night
I forgot about the institution
my experience at home was the greatest
gift
she cared for me like I was her son from
that moment on other workers saw my
potential okay I want to take him home
too
from there it just gradually moved so I
went home with almost the entire staff
that worked there
it's because of them that I learned how
to love how to have compassion how to
care how to have sympathy I mean I had
never done that before I never could
have hugged someone did you see this
happen with any other kids no
I was very fortunate and lucky and
because of their love I believe I was
able to grow and develop a lot better
than others
so how did you get out of this orphanage
these workers called out my name and
another boy's name ciprian
Isidor and chiprian come here
you're going to America
just like that just like them
and we were shocked so they put us in a
nurse's office and I asked who's going
to be my mom
and Marla said I'm going to be your mom
and I said then that's why I want my mom
to be so your parents are here yes Mom
and Dad come right in
good morning Daniel morning
I am marlus
how do you do
you got your own kids yeah you got three
lovely children that you
gonna bring this
mud
into all five of us really wanted him I
thought he was the most Charming thing
yes okay
at first life in America was new and
exciting for Isidore
School playing sports and experienced
something he'd never had before
a family that loved him
but then things start to go wrong they
got to start to go bad I wasn't used to
the family
I didn't care for them
they were not my family and they were
nothing I hated them
all the bitterness I held it in and when
I exploded I took it out on them because
they were the closest to me
there are times where I was so out of
hand the police had to come over
you have any clue
why
I don't know it didn't make sense to me
I mean I don't I couldn't understand it
I think there were just some attachment
issues as a result of you know growing
up without you know someone coddling him
and hugging him and loving on him
when a child grows and develops they
need to be nurtured cared and loved
without it they were mentally affected
by the time is the door turned 16 his
rejection of his adoptive family reached
a boiling point
he moved out of the house seven old ties
with them
but then when he was 18
he learned that marlus and his adoptive
sisters were in a serious car accident
[Music]
ever so devastated and I was very secure
that I was going to lose them
I had done so much damage in the family
that I didn't think I was going to be
accepted or even talked to
all right
they opened the door and I apologized
from them
I remember still to this day he told us
that he loved us
and uh
I'm not sure that we'd ever ever heard
that
but that was a turnaround for him the
beginning yeah
I wasn't willing to give up
he's my son I whether he's My Flesh and
Blood it didn't matter Andrew refused to
give up
once I said that they were able to
forgive me at that moment I made it like
a covenant with myself I did not want to
lose them again
all right so
now what we're still doing the same
thing we have five more children we've
adopted them quite punishment huh
and you what are you doing I'm
advocating for several things because I
definitely don't want to see children
not only in Romania but anyone in the
world
to endure what we endured I think that
the greatest gift of all was being
adopted and be able to have the best
family I have to admit them wow I do
realize that took me a while but hey now
you do
[Music]
when I was a little boy
I had all this
trees grass
sound of birds
had a loving family
it is heartbreaking to learn what is a
door and so many young Romanian children
had to live through
Isidore himself was lucky he had his
nursemaids and his adopted parents
now he dedicates himself to
helping other orphans
securing for them something that was his
vital to their well-being as food and
shelter
blood
[Music]
all of us need to receive love
but giving love often requires sacrifice
many parents stop putting themselves
first they sacrificed their careers work
second jobs or give up their social
lives to care for their children
in some cases the sacrifices we make for
love cause physical pain
and leave lasting scars
thank you
I'm traveling to a remote region of
Southern Ethiopia to visit the village
of the hammer tribe
Anthropologist Dr Samuel defara who has
lived with the Hammond tells me they
will be happy to show me the pain they
endure for love
is this an old related tell me how old
is it she has been here for two three
four centuries
so they're pastoral yes they have goats
they have cows they have sheep because I
was going to ask if I could get eggs
benedict here but I guess not huh yeah I
know okay
[Music]
Village are all members of an extended
family
those tight family bonds are vital to
their survival in this dry and rugged
land
it is sort of joyous sound going on we
are about weakness
jump over the boots with the right of
transition from a childhood to adult oh
okay and then that makes them eligible
to marry
[Music]
the hammer have invited us to witness
that traditional Bowl jumping ceremony
Samuel tells me most of the day's events
aren't focused on the young man who's
coming of age but on his female
relatives
[Music]
the guy was going to live and singing
dancing spreading the family
a crucial part of the ceremony is the
display of love that women make for the
young boy
this is abuse
yeah
[Music]
the hammer people have been holding
Coming of Age Ceremonies for young men
here on the banks of the homo River for
hundreds of years
a central part of the event is his
female relatives being quick
I've heard of other painful ritual
practices often directed against women
but something about this seems different
foreign
[Music]
make sure to do it yeah
hard for me to Fathom because
I don't understand
why the woman wants to get to it
but from their own perspective they are
doing it to show and to express their
love no matter what comes all no matter
what happened to love her brother so
this is the kind of return for the love
that we have for her
Tamil explains that these women know the
boys who are coming of age will make
sacrifices and face dangers hurting
cattle and Ethiopia drug Advanced being
whipped is their way of declaring that
they are willing to endure hardship as
well
but this is also shocking that I want to
ask the women directly why they are
doing this
[Music]
I've been watching for a good while
and I see women getting whipped it seems
painful
and
cruel why do you do it
when your brother lives or when you
honking lips then you have to get
whipped
for them to feel like he's jumping they
have to be whipped
Fresh Cuts lay down on top of old scars
serve as proof of the women's love for
the Bull jumper
it's time now for him to show his
bravery
these are the capitals
and the young man is going to come
jump over a bunch of them yeah he's
going to jump he's very young yeah very
young the Rippers will be lining them up
around there
and then once they are lined up they
will hold tight their horns and their
tents okay so they don't move right so
that they don't move and then the boys
[Music]
yeah he's doing it
what happens if he falls
the young man must run over the cattle
at least four times to complete his
transition to adulthood
the more runs he makes the more of a man
he is in the eyes of his extended family
here's the number four
[Music]
[Applause]
he wants to read more yeah he's coming
back for number five
[Music]
thank you
now we'll become a big man
how many cows could you jump over
I probably could make it over one
Maybe
the strength of the ham and women is
remarkable
and managed to take something painful
and turn it into something that empowers
them
scars that they carry are like a
signature on a contract that says
we are bound by love
strikes me that Human Society may not
have made it without this kind of love
between siblings Aaron and child
it's the basic clue that holds him when
cotton together
the bonds of family are cemented by this
form of sacrificial love
but they are also built on another type
of love
passion that strikes two people
Anthony and Cleopatra
piston and the sword
Romeo and Juliet
these romantic Tales are the epitome of
how we do love
to paraphrase William Shakespeare
love is a fire sparkling in love designs
but I wonder if romantic love alone is
enough to sustain a marriage
only recently and mostly only in
developed countries has marriage based
on passionate love between strangers
replaced marriages arranged by families
as the norm
I'm on my way to Hertfordshire England
to meet lawyer Hannah Bellis whose
Pakistani Heritage presented her with a
choice between both poems of marriage
tell me about your family background
well I was brought up in Andover and
Hampshire although I was actually born
in Pakistan so you grew up here in the
UK yes it was completely all white all
English and so we grew up secluded from
any one of a similar cultural background
to us all
I did and I met someone at University
were you married yes it was what you
would conventionally call a love
marriage it was all very idyllic for a
short while oh sure
a year yeah that's that's shorty yeah I
discovered that actually had been
um unfaithful
so that means divorce it did yes so I
threw myself into my career and I and I
worked very hard
um and became a successful attorney
life in the city as a single girl was
actually quite a lonely experience
even though I had so many friends I knew
that there was something Hollow and
empty and missing in my life and it
wasn't very easy for me with the
experience that I had been through to
easily just trust another and I had a
sort of instinct that I knew I wouldn't
find it just by bumping into someone in
the local supermarket you had to meet
some sort of change I think that's
absolutely right
after a failed first marriage Hina felt
the urge to get reacquainted with her
Pakistani roots
I then had a very good job opportunity
arise so I took that opportunity to take
a break between jobs and take some
proper time out
so I decided to go to Pakistan and meet
my grandmother
after a few days of arriving I noticed
that when we went out to a restaurant
that a strange man would appear and just
be shuffled over to sit next to me and
at first I was unsure as to what the
reason was and then my grandmother would
sort of come over and nudge me
afterwards and say what did you think of
him and I'm like oh it'd be nice if he
could actually string a sentence
together
that's then the penny dropped quite
quickly that my family were effectively
trying to introduce me to a possible
suitable match an arranged marriage what
would you have thinking about the idea
of arranged marriages well it was it was
strange I felt very much that I was a
western woman that had been brought up
in the UK and this was all just not for
me this is not something kind of boring
yes it's foreign it's a bit backward why
would I think about marrying someone in
this way but that's okay I'll I'll humor
you all for a bit I'll sort of go along
with it how many persons do you think
your grandmother paraded before you
there were about four or five as I
recall
and then just as we were about to leave
it was probably the day before
there was another trap and he was very
different extremely Charming had a
wonderful smile good looking I noticed
from across the room my grandmother
looking at me
she had these long slim dark eyes and
she was looking at me and looking at him
like this but what happened was I flew
back to the UK
and literally the day after I arrived my
mother got a phone call from my
grandmother who said I'd like to propose
a match a marriage match between
Cameron and Hina can you ask her if if
that's something that she would be
interested in proceeding with
on the one hand I thought dive in jump
off the cliff and have a go on the other
hand I was thinking what's gone wrong
with you that you're considering this
they're the most conflict in my own mind
because of course I'd only met cam for
about half an hour to an hour
well I think I had a bit of an epiphany
when I was out there because I realized
it may be culturally different to
something that I had
been brought up around but maybe it
wasn't a bad thing maybe there was
something
that it had to offer
I actually said yes I would like to
proceed
and I was thinking you're crazy
[Music]
agreed to marry a man whom she had only
met once for half an hour yeah who lived
more than 4 000 miles away from her home
outside London
she chose to trust the opinion of her
Pakistani family rather than simply rely
on the spark of passion
it was literally no time at all that we
were married over the telephone by a
telephone Nikka ceremony
a nickel ceremony is a wedding ceremony
which is like the actual wedding so this
is sort of at the point of commitment do
you own a telephone he's in Pakistan yes
and you're here in the UK that's right
and you're married now we're technically
married but afterwards I went for a
proper fall ceremony in in Pakistan
[Music]
foreign
it worked out wonderfully
I honestly say I believe I've found my
soulmate
would you like to meet him yeah of
course
hello Cameron
how are you I'm fine so did you know
you're being set up no no not at all
yeah yeah my father he said come what do
you think about the girl of you saw
and
a while
[Laughter]
[Music]
and I said I wish it she'll be my wife
so how long have you been together
15 years
15 years yeah we have an eight and a 10
year old now two beautiful sons
so maybe it's a good thing to have a
family involved in such a momentous
decision I think you're right I think
part of the reason why there are so many
website dating applications this is
because there isn't an easy access to
people is it really meant to just be
chance that you meet someone that you're
meant to spend the rest of your life
with do we really want to leave that
purely to a chance meeting at a party
in Pakistan you always say arranged
marriages and they last long the
blessing from parents I had a lot more
confidence and Trust because I knew that
my family was involved and so there was
a lot more comfort that I had okay so
how how wrong would I be I said yours is
not in a Range to marriage yours is a
marriage by consent the core of the
difference is simply that when a
marriage is arranged it is arranged
because the objective is to introduce
two people for the purposes of getting
married rather than for the purposes of
going out and having fun there are such
things as forced marriages
anyone being compelled to marry someone
they don't want to is completely wrong
an arrangement should be by choice
ultimately we think love has to be
learned there is something powerful
about going into a relationship with a
clear expectations on either side and
clear
hopes and desires on either side and not
having those aspects clouded by the more
superficial feelings there's a
possibility I think that that could lead
to a longer term more lasting more
fulfilling relationship you too look
properly matched to me I mean I can
certainly see how it could come about
between you two looks right feels right
even spells right
it's a long guys thank you
it had never occurred to me that an
arranged marriage could be the
foundation of a loving relationship not
tahina but she and cam have built upon
the expectations placed on their match
by their families
it built a bond that is founded on both
passion and practicality
[Music]
and there isn't a couple of wonderful
boys
[Music]
love has so many forms
it's passionate
it's painful
[Music]
it's nurtured
love binds people together
even when love is the last thing on
their minds
[Music]
I'm meeting Army Major William Swenson
who received the Medal of Honor for his
bravery in Afghanistan will Swenson was
there for his brothers he was there for
us all
the story of how he risked his life for
his brothers in arms
is a true story of love
[Applause]
[Music]
Brothers in Arms what does that term
mean to you
it's a term that's always defined our
relationship to one another in the
military friendship a family that's
forged whether it's basic training or
whether it's an experience that was
forged in war
now you were in Afghanistan
that's correct
we had U.S army
U.S Air Force and U.S Navy assets all
participating in the joint operation to
help pacify a troubled part of our
region
collectively working with respective
Afghan partners
Sergeant First Class Kenneth Westbrook
and I were working with our Afghan
border patrol
Sergeant Westbrook was
in effect my right hand man
Sergeant Westbrook is a friend of yours
we had not known each other prior to
this deployment we got to know each
other very well I could rely on him we
were very different in every way however
we ultimately saw that we had an
objective a goal and that we are going
to get there together
on September 8 2009 major Swenson
Sergeant Westbrook and their Afghan
border patrol Unit were tasked with
escorting a contingent from the Afghan
Army and the U.S Marines
they were headed to a meeting of Elders
in the village of ganjugal
but this was not a mission that intended
on being combat we were there to support
that operation okay so whatever you pick
your battles but sometimes your battles
pick you
the mission came under Fire that's
correct
we never entered the village before we
were fired upon and it rapidly escalated
into a significant amount of direct
accurate lethal fire
[Music]
major William Swenson had set out on a
mission to help afghanist soldiers
broker a peace deal with tribal Elders
in the village of ganjika
thank you
all of a sudden the mission came under
attack
and they were surrounded by as many as
60 Insurgent Fighters
he and his entire Unit were battling to
save their own lives
we had received at least four of our
first casualties within the first five
minutes
this battle extended over six hours
and over these six hours we had
a number of heroic Acts that occurred
across that Battlefield we were firmly
committed to one goal
extracting our survivors recovering our
wounded and dead
and getting off that Battlefield so we
could come back and fight another day
major Swenson repeatedly entered the
Kill Zone to rescue wounded and Fallen
U.S and Afghani soldiers
he wasn't alone in his efforts
starting first class Westbrook was
providing supporting fire heroically
and he was wounded and he called out to
me well I'm hit
and he didn't tell me how badly wounded
he was he never indicated how
significant his injuries were but they
were grave
and
I was watching him I was checking to
make sure he was okay and he was
and he provided cover and Fire
for who knows how long before he finally
said
I'm losing it
I need help over here
and I knew he was serious
and I went over to him and he and I
began to extract off the battlefield
and he on his own two feet walked
hundreds of yards hundreds of yards
through complex Terrain but again I had
not at this point understood the
severity of it
push this together
this helicopter crew was Under Fire at
this time
for them to land a helicopter full of
fuel in that areas
Testament to their bravery as well
this
is the desk you see is providing some
level of protection from direct fire
you hear that Sergeant First Class
Westboro coming out
the bullet had destroyed his shoulder
internal damage and bleeding
at this point he'd lost so much blood
that it was difficult for him to
maintain cautiousness
this is from Sergeant First Class
Westbrook walking I was on two feet off
that Battlefield after doing his job
at that point told him he'd done his job
it's time to go home and I gave him a
kiss on the head
your brother in arms you gave a kiss on
the head
would you agree
it qualifies
This Love
this qualifies love
the people you serve with
the people you go to conflict with the
people that you haven't experienced in
that intensity
forges friendships it forages bonds it
forges something that truly cannot be
repeated anywhere else
what happens on those battlefields what
happens amongst our service members in
those situations
create something that really cannot be
described
it can be seen it can be witnessed
but it really has to be felt
it's powerful and it extends Beyond just
the soldier just that sailor that Marine
it extends to even their families you
feel like you've forged a new family a
new Bond
so Sergeant Westbrook was rather
severely wounded but not mortally right
what happened to her
Sergeant Westbrook had the opportunity
to go home
he didn't want to he wanted to stay keep
fighting
he got to go home
he got to see his family
unfortunately
as a result of complications he passed
away a month later
back in the United States
with his family by his side
so out of all of that
he died
This Is War
it's not fair
[Music]
he would return to that Battlefield if
he could have he would have returned
right by my side and he and I would have
continued our mission
but he gave
everything for what he loved for what he
believed in
and
I take some solace in knowing that he
got home
yeah
talking about it isn't it
thank you
[Music]
the coverage that made to Swenson showed
on that fateful day is inspiring
but what strikes me most is that kiss
what it reveals
it's not romantic
no
no it's
a kiss of Fellowship
a profound
bond with someone you have no blood dies
with
how could we ever have moved Beyond
small tribes without that Bond
how cities
our entire nations
could not exist
Without Love
has built our world
but not everyone receives the love they
need
around us there are people who are
excluded
who feel invisible to the rest of
society
can we help bring them back
simply by offering them love
[Music]
across Europe and North America there
are nearly 5 million homeless
some of us are moved to help these
people through charity
you could code Charities organizations
built from Love
in the U.S 63 million volunteers donated
8 billion hours to homelessness and
other causes in 2016.
but suffering persists all the same
I wonder if there's a better way to show
love for those in need
I'm in London to meet Joshua Coombs
he's a hairdresser and he believes small
acts of love can make a big impact
how you doing I'm doing good good to see
you great to meet you what uh what am I
doing with this store I'm going to show
you okay
so um I'm gonna take you around Packham
was once one of London's most
downtrodden neighborhoods
today it's in transition
on the same block you can find trendy
coffee shops street gangs
and the homeless
I'm going to talk to this guy down here
quickly okay just a sec
Joshua hopes he can help the homeless
not by offering them money or food
but by giving them a haircut
okay still
when was the last time you had a haircut
in November last year December January
February five months March April
how do you come to be homeless George I
broke my hip
and they shocked my benefits and at the
time I was like how stupid they was
getting involved with drugs and things I
didn't really care and the next thing I
remember you know they came and I said
write you out that was the 24th of
January
2016 and I've been homeless since
there's another world on the street
he can't go home anymore
you know you're alone
well I came close once in 1962
to couldn't pay my rent and I had I had
four roommates
but uh
I couldn't pay my rent for a couple of
months and they said well you gotta go I
had my duffel bag on my shoulders I'm
thinking now where am I gonna go
whereabouts was that San Francisco San
Francisco
luckily I had friends
somebody took me in
a lot of people look at you they think
you know it's your faultier then did you
serve it you've done something wrong
yeah it wasn't my case I mean
it's built up
um
how long you been doing this John for a
couple of years now
so what got you started I think it was
feeling a bit helpless really if I'm
honest like it came from a field of
helplessness of how can I affect a
problem that seems so big how do I begin
to stop from that feeling of
helplessness came like I had to start
one person just talking to one person
finding out about them and I think that
makes you feel empowered to make bigger
changes
a bit more than giving a haircut or
getting a haircut yeah exactly right
just because we're not related I feel
like there's got to be those support for
the people who don't have that and um
but I know a haircut's not a big thing I
know it's not going to change somebody's
world but for me it's just a way of
spending time with someone it's a way of
making someone hopefully feel like
there's someone out there who cares even
if that is a stranger right so yeah
this is it about it's just coming off
I've got a free number there I think
I've got two
okay you ready to say goodbye to this
mustache it's gone it's going going gone
well I must say okay look human
but I'm a fake who do you think Stuart
you say my name you're talking to me and
I recognize your voice you know it's
like oh do you now
do you have a special sleeping place
okay if you go away that I've slept in a
few months now the Security's unboxing
me
on the street your day today what would
you say love means to you
[Music]
I'm uh I'm doing my sleeping bag just
climbing that and somebody walked myself
morning wow lovely but when you don't
hear a good morning from anything yeah
another big reason to do this when
people walk past and they see someone
helping another person I think it's
infectious it ripples you know and I
think
that's that's part of this to try and
Inspire other people
so we've created a social media movement
hashtag do something for nothing
and people are using this hashtag in
different places to perform Goodwill
acts you know so it's not just about
hedges
so let's do it I'm thinking now what's
got Josh here with you is his sense of
Love Thy Neighbor
do something
or someone for nothing
what do you think about that
could be a lot more dumb
yeah
yeah man and Final Touch we ready
I think there you are thank you but you
don't recognize this guy I don't yeah
in five
four
three
two
one ta-da
20 years younger okay yeah it's true
you're a new man right now thank you how
do you feel
like a new man like a new man yeah do
you recognize yourself then
um
yeah yeah I used to do a lot of money I
was a lot younger
all right so but I want to say to the
both of you is thank you very much thank
you very much thank you
quite a new experience
someone like you walking around in the
city doing good stuff like that thank
you that's really nice let's do it
thank you it's really terrific what Josh
is doing we're gonna see you again soon
thanks
Joshua doesn't expect these small acts
of kindness to end homelessness
but he hopes to love he shows people
will boost their self-esteem and may
help them rebuild their lives
just imagine
if each of us
took five minutes out of your day to do
something loving to another person
I don't care if it's a family member or
your friend or a total stranger
imagine what a transformation we could
make in this world
love is the most powerful force we know
back when we all lived in small tribes
that kept our extended families together
but it has grown into so much more than
that today love can reach all the way
around the world
it is endlessly adaptable surprising
and healing it has the power to inspire
us to push our society forward
I still believe love can change the
world like I did in 1967
we just have to remember
there's nothing we can do that can't be
done
with love
foreign
[Music]